Cardi B threw her shoe
at Nicki Minaj during
Harper Bazaar's Fashion
Week party, and was swiftly
stopped by Nicki's security.
So I guess it's safe to assume that there
won't be any collabs in the near future.
♪ These is bloody shoes ♪ ♪
Cardi took to Instagram
shortly after the event,
insinuating that Nicki
had supported negative
comments about her child
and her parenting styles.
Nicki, fully addressed it
on her Queen radio show,
Nicki vehemently denied
saying anything negative
about Cardi's parenting.
After criticizing Cardi's
attack on her and two
other women on a separate
occasion, Nicki said
she found evidence of the
rapper calling another
woman's black child a monkey.
The child had passed away,
and Nicki had the mother
call in to her radio show
to confirm the story.
The harshest warning came
when Nicki warned Cardi
about the dangers of her
actions, saying quote...
While this was definitely
not a direct threat from
Nicki, it's still really really messy.
But the Fashion Week
incident is just the latest
event in a beef that's
been going on for a while.
Here's how it all began.
Cardi B entered the
mainstream with her single
"Bodak Yellow" in June of 2017.
♪ I don't dance now,
I make money moves ♪ ♪
Previously, her huge
Instagram presence, mixtapes,
and scene-stealing appearances
on "Love & Hip-Hop"
quickly made Cardi an artist to watch.
"Bodak Yellow" topped the
Billboard charts and she
became the second female
rapper in history to hold
the number one spot without any features.
The first was Lauryn Hill back in 1998.
And because she's such a
successful female rapper,
media and fans immediately
began comparing her to
Nicki, an established and
successful female rapper
who's been in the game for over a decade.
♪ Lemme get this straight,
wait, I'm the rookie? ♪ ♪
At first, the two artists
don't take the bait.
Nicki actually congratulated
Cardi on Bodak Yellow's
success, and while Cardi
is shown aligning herself
with artists that have
notoriously spoke against
Nicki, like Lil' Kim and
Remy Ma, when asked about
Nicki, Cardi stays pretty neutral.
Cardi B: You know, I love
Lil Kim, I love Trina, I
like Remy Ma, I love
Nicki, I love all of them.
With the success of her
single, Cardi was asked to
jump on "MotorSport" with
her now-husband's group,
Migos, and Nicki Minaj.
When the song first came
out, rumors spread that
Nicki didn't know that Cardi
B would be on the track,
and that some lines were direct shots.
Originally, in the line..
Quavo was Cardi.
The whole ordeal resulted
in some genuinely
hurt feelings, which Nicki revealed on her
first interview back after a few months'
hiatus.
In April 2018, Nicki
gave a raw interview with
Beats radio, essentially
saying that Cardi didn't
give her the proper respect
for the "MotorSport"
feature.
Cardi B: And when I heard the track
Host: Right.
Cardi B: Her verse wasn't
finished, or it's not the
verse that it was now, and you know, Quavo
told me to get on the
song, and I just felt
like it was a perfect
opportunity for me to
be on the track that's big like them.
Nicki Minaj: The first
interview that she did after
"MotorSport" came out,
it just really hurt me.
Cause she looked so aggravated and angry.
Alana: She said the
incident really hurt her
feelings, and that she
felt attacked by her
own people.
Nicki Minaj: It's because
of the Nicki hate parade
that she felt the
comfortability to address
me in that manner.
Alana: The two spoke at
the Met Gala and it seemed
their issues were finally put to rest.
A photographer took a
few shots of the two in a
seemingly happy conversation.
According to an interview
with Howard Stern, Cardi
said that the conversation
was about an issue that
truly hurt Cardi's feelings.
Nicki Minaj dropped her
latest album "Queen"
three months later, and
the internet wasn't done
fanning the flames.
In a few of her songs,
Nicki takes indirect jabs at
rappers that fans say may
or may not include Cardi.
Nicki repeatedly emphasizes
that she writes her own
bars and that she wants
female rappers to write their
own bars, too.
Nicki Minaj: Everybody on the
inside of the industry knows
that I write my lyrics and
knows that I put so much weight
on women writing.
Alana: Cardi B has candidly
said that she doesn't
write all her own music.
In her recent Queen radio
episode, Nicki further
takes a jab at Cardi, and
accuses Cardi of paying
for her tracks to be played
on the radio.
ALANA: Before the fame,
it's no secret that Cardi B
used to strip.
While Nicki never confirmed
that these lyrics were
about Cardi B specifically,
it's really hard to deny
there wasn't the tiniest
bit of shade thrown.
Nicki Minaj: Oh, no shade.
Alana: Deep down, I hope
that these two really
dope artists can just put
their differences aside
and give their fans the
collabs we all really want.
Do you think that the
tension will die down or are
they just getting started?
Let us know in the comments
below and don't forget
to subscribe!